merci oui je vous comprends vous êtes au
front dr weiss depuis deux jours vous
attardez vous entendez peut-être pas
mais je vais vous le raconter parce que
vous travaillez les premier ministre et
monsieur trudeau et monsieur legault qui
insiste en disant la vie normale c'est
dans plusieurs plusieurs plusieurs mois
et tant qu'on aura pas de vaccin on va
devoir vivre avec cette menace là et c
est que ça prendra donc un an et demi a
dit monsieur trudeau ce matin ans qu'on
puisse sans aucun problème
faire des câlins à nos grands parents à
nos parents ex bon est-ce que vous avez
là même le même horizon temps dans votre
esprit
quand vous pensez à ça vous vous savez
ça fait longtemps qu'on a dit qu'il ya
deux choses qui vont être vraiment ce
qu'on appelle des ging challenger qui
vont vraiment changé le paysage de façon
complète soit on a un nouveau médicament
directement actifs contre le virus kovy
19 ou bien on a un vaccin efficace donc
c'est l'un ou chez l'autre
à partir du moment où du moment on se
retrouve dans cette situation et le
vaccin serait probablement encore une
meilleure option
on va si on va se retrouver dans un
risque de menaces qui va être diminué de
façon très importante
alors oui il va falloir penser à minimum
une année dans le meilleur des cas pour
un vaccin parce qu'il faut quand même
montré que le vaccin est efficace vous à
les administrer un vaccin des gens et il
faut montrer qu'il est sécuritaire
donc on a au moins une année devant nous
avant de pouvoir revenir parce qu'on
appellera une vie normale qui était
avant le corona et après le corner bon
dans cette année là où cette année mis
dans votre esprit il faut s'assurer que
les personnes vulnérables dont les
personnes de 70 ans et plus soit
davantage protégés mais dans votre
esprit savait pas dire qu'il reste
pendant un an et demi
ces gens-là plus âgés confiné non tout à
fait il va falloir à un moment donné
retourner à une vie plus normale
en réalité en ce qu'on veut et ce qu'on
a déjà dit c'est qu'on va avoir une
grosse vague initial et qu'on a essayé
d'aplatir donc un tsunami qui cette qui
veut se transformer en une grosse vague
et qui va être suivi de vagues l'est
pendant quelque temps jusqu'au moment où
une grosse partie de la population aura
été infectée et éventuellement à ce
moment là le virus empêchera sa
propagation par lui même par le fait
qu'il a de moins en moins de clients
entre temps il va falloir définitivement
protéger les gens les plus vulnérables
pour les complications de ce virus là et
on s'aperçoit que bon c'est
principalement les personnes en hausse
de 70 ans qui au québec 17 de la maladie
maintenant il faut pas oublier qu'il ya
aussi des gens qui ne décèdent pas mais
qui sont malades qui sont dans les
hôpitaux qui sont sur des ventilateurs
et ainsi de suite alors si par exemple
je veux aller faire un câlin à ma mère
qu'elle 80 quelques-uns est-ce que je
devrais savoir si j'ai eu la maladie si
je les hais ce que parce que si nos
logiquement là si on suit cette logique
là qu'il faut protéger les gens
vulnérables
jusqu'au jour où on aura un vaccin les
personnes âgées on pourra pas s'y
approcher d'aussi près là c'est ce qui
qui est difficile à imaginer mais ouais
je pense que on n'ira pas jusque là on
va voir il va falloir voir comment le
scénario du film va se dérouler il ya
grosse portion de la population qui à un
moment donné va affecter
donc disons que vous êtes là madame qui
veut aller faire un monsieur qui va
aller faire un câlin sommaire massy
éventuellement un moment donné vous vous
êtes infecté vous développer la maladie
vous passez au travers vous en
guérissent et et c'est quelque chose qui
est dans le passé puis c'est fini par
vous allez être en quelque sorte
protéger donc vous serez plus un vecteur
pour la maladie en question n'ont donc
un moment donné il va avoir un certain
nombre d'individus qui vont avoir été
malade et qui vont donc avoir été
protégés au fond et ces gens là ne sont
plus une menace alors son situation qui
va évoluer
on va aussi apprendre à mieux traiter
lakovic 19 on va améliorer raffiner nos
traitements on va avoir des études
éventuellement sous peut-être des
molécules pour l'aspect prophylaxie donc
il ya beaucoup de choses qui vont
s'améliorer je veux dire dans les six ou
neuf prochains mois
ok mais d'accord mais je reviens ce que
vous dites là c'est intéressant c'est ce
qui veut dire que ça mais n'est pas de
la pression pour avoir des tests
disponible pour que je reprends le même
exemple si je veux aller physiquement à
voir ma mère qui est qui est âgée je
veux pas la m je pense que paul dû
transmettre bien sûr le virus
je dois savoir si je n'ai eu que je ne
l'est plus donc je peux à y aller
facilement donc ce qui veut dire que je
pourrai il faut que j'ai accès un test
pour savoir si jeunes les u ou pas ben
tout à fait éventuellement on va avoir
des tests sérologiques c'est à dire des
tests qui vont permettre de détecter la
présence de certains types d'anticorps
dans votre sens et qui vont vous dire
oui vous êtes protégés ou non vous
n'êtes pas protégé
une fois qu'on va être arrivé à cette
étape là et qu'on va rôder anticorps qui
vont être spécifique et la chute
importante je souligne demande
spécifique contre la copie de 19 à ce
moment là ce sera définitivement un
outil qui va nous permettre de savoir
qui est protégé qu'il n'est pas pourquoi
j'ai dit spécifique parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de virus corona on en a déjà
parlé
certains de ces virus là sont très bénin
responsable d'un simple rue et
probablement que vous aimez on a déjà
des anticorps contre ces virus la corona
parce que on a toujours fait on a tous
fait un rhume dans notre vie et donc il
faut montrer que les anticorps contre
lakovic 19 sont vraiment ce compte-là
kovy 19 et non pas contre tous les
autres virus corona qu'on a pu
rencontrer dans notre vie ok et ça ça va
être une partie de la difficulté de ces
tests de là et à kehl mama on aura ces
tests là indisponible pour le grand
public
d'après vous comment on travaille là
dessus c'est clair mais il va falloir
avoir peut-être un je veux dire ainsi
mois devant nous donc on va voir des
tests qui vont avoir été fiable démontré
et prouvé qu en étant efficace donc on
est un peu condamnés pendant six mois
anne autre chose s'approcher trop dur
gens qui sont les plus vulnérables c'est
ça on verra on prend la mesure de sol
oui jusqu'à un certain point faudra
faire attention j'ai pas de boule de
cristal mais disons vous avez fait
lakovic 19 là les quatre cafés la
commune et un mois et demi plus tard
cette personne-là est en pleine forme et
c'est quelqu'un dise on vous êtes
quelqu'un en bonne santé normalement
dont vous avez fait la copie 19
vous avez été malade mais pas tous
malade puis vous avez complètement
guérie et ans et vous l'avez fait parce
qu'on vous a testé on vous a fait un
test groupe star bon bah deux mois après
vous allez être pas vous n'allez pas
être infectieux savoir aller voir les
gens qui leur disent bonjour puis allez
voir vos parents vos grands parents bien
pas de problème pour ces gens là oui
c'est ça sur la effectivement vous avez
raison cela il n'y a pas de problème
c'est laisser les eaux qui ne le savent
pas où il faut il faudra rester faudra
rester prudent
non j'allais vous prendre quelques
questions du public la deuxième j'ai 70
ans j'ai reçu un résultat positif
mais est-ce normal que j'éprouve encore
plusieurs symptômes en parler de rhume
tout à l'heure le mal de gorge
courbatures et fatigue après plus de 24
jours à ce que y a des est ce qu'il ya
des gens qui qui ont besoin de plus de
temps pour s'en débarrasser oui tout à
fait alors la bonne nouvelle c'est que
si ça fait vingt-quatre jours que vous
avez des symptômes et que vous avez
votre caisse tient peut-être plus de 14
ou c'est que vous êtes probablement dans
la bonne phase d'évolution de la maladie
c'est à dire on sait que les gens qui
vont compliquer vont compliquer à partir
du jour 7,8 des symptômes
donc si vous êtes de 24 jours c'est que
vous avez passé le gros homard fière de
vous et vous êtes sortis du bois
maintenant que vous restiez avec des
symptômes de fatigue que vous restiez
avec des symptômes de courbatures c'est
encore possible
deux choses sont importantes fait plus
de fièvre et vous n'êtes pas essoufflé
si vous n'avez pas ces deux symptômes là
c'est un peu normal que tranquillement
vous allez vous débarrasser des autres
symptômes mais le plus dur est derrière
vous bon bravo numéro 6 une inquiétude
hnatow une inquiétude n'attendent pas
l'autre je me pose la question que
restera-t-il de notre système
immunitaire
après tout cet isolement et j'ajouterais
après tout ce lavage de mains qui s'est
tramé bon confinement lorsque nous
mettrons à nouveau le nez dehors
vous avez pas vous inquiéter parce que
votre système immunitaire continue de
travailler normalement le système
immunitaire
c'est pas juste contre des bactéries ou
des virus et aussi contre beaucoup de
choses dans l'environnement sap
répondent des pollens d'ailleurs c'est
important de le noter qu'on va rentrer
dans la saison 2
argy ça va un petit peu compliqué le
tableau parce que si vous souffrez
d'allergies et que vous êtes saisonnière
c'est peut-être le moment idéal de bien
commencer vos médicaments pour pas
commencé à avoir des symptômes
d'allergie que vous allez mettre sur la
clause 8 19
donc les symptômes que vous allez avoir
c'est important avec le système
immunitaire
il ya beaucoup de choses que raciste un
militaire va faire d'un système
immunitaire il s'occupe par exemple de
s'assurer qu'on n'a pas une cellule
cancéreuse qui se développe en nous
notre système immunitaire s'assure que
lens vous avez des allergies dans votre
environnement vous vous défendiez dont
vous avez aussi un papier d'allergènes
entre guillemets ou de substances dans
votre maison
dans vos conduits d'aération épices et
c'est tout à fait normal qu'ils vont
faire que vous allez garder votre
système immunitaire à l'entraînement
donc il y aura aucun risque de
confinement est d'avoir un système
immunitaire fatigué lorsque vous allez
sortir de là dr weiss merci beaucoup je
vous laisse tranquille demain et pour la
fin de semaine courage continuez
tenez bon et merci encore de ce prêt de
vous prêter à cet exercice c'est très
apprécié par nos téléspectateurs alors
simple plaisir joyeuses pâques à tout le
monde qui restez chez vous voilà promis
c'est clair merci novembre à rabat